what do you think's going to happen with
the with the real-estate market
generally speaking over the next year or
two or even ten
well what real estate mark are you
talking about I guess we'll start with
because I know we're in different
countries with different types of deals
the types of toss deals that you're
doing in the in the United States what
are you thinking what are you thinking
there well we have well have a built up
1.5 billion dollars but the real estate
today will be worth three billion
dollars in ten years so you think you
think long-term
things are gonna continue rising 100
percent like like now now if I owned a
30 million-dollar house down in Miami I
don't think it's gonna be worth 30
million 10 years from now I think it's
gonna be worth less mm-hmm so single
family small deals duplexes and for
plexes in America probably aren't going
to be worth more maybe they are but
they're not gonna be worth much more and
they're gonna be hard to keep they'll
probably be a lot of different owners
between now and then because they won't
cash flow if it doesn't cash flow it's
gonna see the reason I asked you what
kind of real estate is because there's
so many different kinds of real estate
there's residential single-family home
there's two units commercial four units
commercial six units eight units
commercial that we have over here
there's townhomes
there's retail there's strip centers
there's office there's industrial
there's storage and then there's
residential multifamily that I buy the
multifamily off there's office buildings
offices gonna get hurt
retail is gonna get crushed strip
centers are gonna get destroyed movie
theaters will cease to exist
industrial will continue to expand
apartment residential will do great as
long as it's great properties great
amenities affordable the stuff that you
guys buy over there it's gonna depend on
location do you think they could ever
type property I think the government
could ever just stop taking property off
people because it gets so bad they don't
want to do that there's still homes back
from 2008 12 years ago that people have
been late on for 12 years they haven't
taken back they don't want to take
people's property back they can't even
manage what they have well we can't even
manage the roads here
you know folks are saying wait until the
crash happens wait until everything
drops and then go in what what do you
what do you think about that well you're
not gonna be you're not gonna be well
by the time that happens if you want if
you I just say this if you didn't buy
anything last year the chance of you
buying something this year are almost
nil just tonight
Oh we're gonna wait until it bottoms out
okay all right whatever
like you you're not gonna you know the
great stuff there are so many people
lined up waiting for the great stuff
yeah you're gonna be like three blocks
down the list
I saw this in 2009 or when I was buying
into doesn't know how I got started and
everyone was saying we're gonna wait
we're gonna wait but then suddenly 2011
where I was everything's shooting up
again and all these people that say
we're going away I've now mystic is when
he goes up he goes up fast and there's
suddenly a cube he only has to start up
a little smidgen there's a queue of
people then yeah you should be out
looking how to buy real estate right now
be my suggestion to you yeah well you
should be in your portfolio right now my
real estate got me through 2008 okay
renters the renter market improved I'm
buying stuff to keep it it's monopoly
yeah for me it's rent right I just want
you to land on that my place and pay me
rent if you just keep going around the
board dude I got stuff if I can keep it
and you keep going around the board
sooner or later you have to pay me rent
extremely interesting calls from Grant
Cardone I'd love to know what your
thoughts are please do comment them
below as I'm really really curious also
the full interview is gonna be coming
soon with me
but we go to much more detail around
real estate the economy business what's
gonna happen predictions so do subscribe
to the channel for that interview pretty
soon you can subscribe right here what
if you want to see my thoughts um what I
think's gonna happen with the property
market particularly in the UK then check
out the video right here see you soon
subscribe